high heels luca
[Musik]
pavels luca herzlich willkommen wir
heute zu einem neuen video auf einem
kanal meine lieben freunde geht es
bereits um titel und zwar rufe ich euch
heute mit meinem handy mit was auch
sonst ich habe da der instagram sorry
gesagt dass ihr mir gerne per bm eure
nummer zuwenden könnte dann rufe ich
euch an allerdings habe ich euch noch
nicht gesagt dass sie auch etwas
gewinnen können sicher im supermarkt 425
euro aktionen geschenkkarten getaucht
und die leute die ich gleich anrufen
werde den werde ich sagen hey wir
spielen jetzt gegen das schiere statt
papier und wenn die andere person
gewinnt bekommt sie eine 25 euro amazon
geschenkt hatte die sache ist allerdings
dass sie nur gewinnen können also ich
lasse sie quasi gewinnen so ein bisschen
wie da wird doppelt das letztens gemacht
hat von daher würde ich sagen ich rufe
jetzt direkt die erste person an gm
gewesen und habe ich jetzt angerufen
wir haben die rente sicher gegangen und
habe ich eine der obersten gerade
genommen deswegen hier geht hier ist
dann kann er ja mit jetzt auch sehr gut
danke schön
allerdings möchte ich eine ganz kurze
sache mit dir machen und zwar habe ich
für das heutige video ein paar amazon
geschenkkarten gekauft und wert von 25
euro und wir spielen jetzt gegen anders
schere stein papier und wenn du gewinnst
dann bekommst du diese 25 euro geschenkt
hatte schere stein papier
y
[Musik]
ja kein problem
vielleicht sehen uns ja dann das nächste
mal in köln stuttgart oder ich komme
doch stadtrat stimmt da bin ich auch
jetzt hatte dankeschön zu denken die
andere erst person war eigentlich
unentschieden aber ich habe gesagt ich
lass die leute gewinnen
hallo hier ist luca hallo ich hätte gar
nicht gedacht dass ich direkt erreichen
du hast mir gar keine handynummer
gegeben sondern ich glaube das war eine
normale festnetznummer oder das
steinerne nummer das doch deine
handynummer okay dann bin ich einfach
ich habe aber was vorbereitet wird
heutige video zwar würde ich gern
schwere stein papier spielen gegen dich
und wenn du gewinnst bekommst du von je
25 euro amazon geschenkkarte papier
ich wünsche dir weiterhin viel erfolg
berufskollege und viel spaß bei den
hausaufgaben aber passt ja jetzt erst
mal wochenende okay man sieht sehe ich
glaube hält 1040 voll schön anlegen mit
den leuten etwas zu schenken ob wenn es
nur ja nur 25 euro seien karten sind
kann aber es war heute irgendwie im rewe
und ich sagte man einfach so hey da
steht so ein adventskalender und daneben
waren so wie wir uns das ist was hinter
alles netflix karten export amazon apple
keine ahnung was man dachte ich jeder
bestellt sich eigentlich ab und zu sagen
bei amazon
und dann habe ich einfach 100 euro
ausgegeben für vier so karten und ja ich
würde sagen wir rufen die nächste person
und ich leider gar nicht so lange ich
bin aufgeregter als die leute selbst
glaube ich dass luca
[Musik]
dann gefällt den anderen fährt ja kein
problem allerdings hast du dich gleich
eventuell noch mal bei mir bedanken und
zwar weil ich heute morgen und
supermarkt und hab mir mal eine amazon-
25 euro geschenkt karte gekauft und ich
habe mir gedacht die spieler jetzt
schere stein papier gegen dich und wenn
du gewinnst dann gebe ich dir den court
und dann hast du quasi 25 euro gewonnen
schere stein papier
ich hab mir dann kann ich mich noch mal
ja kein problem was machst du schreiben
dann kann ich dir den code eben sagen
und dann noch die sonst hoffe ich dass
du noch ein wunderschönen tag hat sich
wirklich eine ganz ganz gute besserung
und vielleicht sehen wir uns ja mal
danke schön weiter voll spontane idee
gerade so wie bereits gesagt die
vereinfachten supermarkt
wir hängen sehen und dachte hey bevor
ich euch heute einfach so normale anrufe
wäre vielleicht ganz lustig wenn ich ja
ja ich glaub ich schon oft genug erklärt
also wir rufen jetzt die letzte person
fürs heutige video an
hallo hier ist luca ich mich nimmt das
video auf und ich gehe die ganze nach
oben und scrollt weil sie durch werden
neue aktualität nämlich mal die oberste
person soll rein aus zufallsprinzip
ja du ich hatte aber ein kleines spiel
vorbereitet und zwar hat jede person die
ich heute anrufe die chance einer 25
euro amazon geschenkkarte zu gewinnen
werden die personen gegen mich schere
stein papier gewinnt weil ich bin
ziemlich guter schere stein papier
spieler
[Musik]
ansonsten wünsche ich dir weiterhin viel
erfolg für das abitur ich hoffe du
verstehst das ganze und noch ein schönes
wochenende
dankeschön mich erfüllt das gerade voll
mit freude irgendwie allerdings will ich
an der stelle das heutige video endet
meine lieben freunde wenn es euch
gefallen hatte mich sehr denn dort aber
einen daumen hoch unter dem video hier
freuen schreibt mir gern und in die
kommentare auch nicht öfter so was
machen soll also wenn beispielsweise
westermann rufen
das wäre auch ganz lustig und wenn ich
dann noch weitere sachen machen sollen
so challenges wie jetzt ihr mit den
gutscheinen dann schreiben wir auch
gerne in den kommentaren abonniert man
kann halt falls doch keiner seite und
ich müsse
[Musik]